within minutes of Phillip Hammonds
budget announcement that he was putting
up national insurance contributions for
the self-employed there was outrage much
of it from his own party's backbenchers
amid accusations a manifesto pledge had
been broken today exactly a week on the
Chancellor back down although he still
maintained that the commitment applied
only to class one contributions and not
the class force paid by the
self-employed it is very important both
to me and to my right honourable friend
the Prime Minister that we comply not
just with the letter but also the spirit
of the community
therefore as I set out in my letter this
morning to the chairman of the Select
Committee my right honourable friend the
member for chit Chester I have decided
not to proceed with the class for next
measures set out in the budget there
will be no increases in National
Insurance contribution rates in this
Parliament and I will set out in the
autumn budget further measures to fund
in full today's decision Chris Bryce is
chief executive of the association of
independent professionals and the
self-employed and torsten bellies in our
Westminster studio he's the director of
the resolution foundation which
campaigns to improve the living
standards of those on low to middle
income and he called for a rise in the
national insurance contributions paid by
the self-employed will Chris let me
start with you this move this climb down
is going to leave a black hole in the
budget of around a billion pounds how do
you propose the Chancellor fills it well
I quite happy to sit with the Chancellor
and go through the the issue with it but
I 11 area you could take a look at is
the lack of national employers national
insurance contributions made for
part-time workers I am pretty sure we
could fill the whole coin quickly if we
looked at that that would still be
attacks on jobs of course it well
national insurance is that the tanks on
jobs and but the real issues in fact the
way that we work in a 21st century
economy and in fact a drain is up review
of the entire taxation systems what's
really required we have a 19th century
tax system 21st century economy the two
just don't mix now the Institute of
fiscal studies which of course is you
know revered on all issues to do with
tax they thought this was actually quite
a sensible move and also a progressive
move I mean this is basically a bung to
the better off him backing down like
this is well know it that's not exactly
correct this tax cuts in around 16,000
pounds so somebody believing lip earning
below the living wage could in fact have
more tax apply to well except that the
Chancellor's abolishing class to Nick's
so it still leaves lower-paid
self-important people better off it
leaves those up to about 16,000 pounds
slightly better of 8,000 pounds is the
the ideal if you like but in fact
anybody above 16,000 pounds would be
would have been paying more time
but the fact remains you now have in a
lot of cases people in the city
well-paid IT professionals for example
doing exactly the same job as salaried
employees and paying a fraction of the
tax oh they do well that's a slightly
different case because they're generally
working through limited companies rather
than paying sole proprietor or sole
trader national insurance about taking
your point those people have opted to
work in a flexible way to provide their
services and flexible way to clients who
want them to work flexibly and they've
taken a huge risk upon themselves so I
think tax differential is justified and
fair well torsten Bell let me bring you
in at this point torsten so tossed
another you would argue presumably this
is not a very good thing because you
thought it was quite a progressive
measure didn't you well this is a
slightly odd you turn from the
Chancellor today because he's both said
that the policy is totally the right
thing to do and also he's not going to
go ahead with it so that made it not
normally what you get in u-turns and the
reason he's done those because obviously
the politics and this is difficult the
politics of all tax rises difficult
nobody wants money taken out of their
pocket and politicians don't like taking
it in general so the politics is
difficult that's compounded by a thing
called a manifesto which I'll leave
others to judge how difficult that makes
it but on the substance the Chancellor
is absolutely right and he's right
because the gap in tax paid by the
self-employed compared to employees is
big and actually is now growing because
of what you mentioned earlier the
abolition of class to national insurance
but the gap between what the
self-employed get out from the system
compared to employees is shrinking at
the same time because the self-employed
will now get the same state pension as
employees for the first time and that
was the big gap between the two groups
of people and what justified the
difference in in tax so the docs was
right to look at closing that gap the M
as I say the politics haven't worked out
from as you say the justification the
Chancellor used was that now we got a
flat rate pension system effectively the
self-employed are making the same
demands on the status as they employed
is there a case given that he's wound
back on that to say well self-employed
people shouldn't get us generous of
state pension asst employed people well
I wouldn't say that I mean it's very
important that we have a broad
and level base for pension saving
encourage other people to save on their
own behalf and there was a problem with
the self-employed not having enough
pension savings in the past and I don't
think that's the answer to the question
the answer the question is a fairer tax
system that catches up as your and other
guest was saying with the well the way
the world of work has changed forty-five
percent of the growth in self-employment
in recent years in employment in recent
years has been amongst the self-employed
they've been driving it then and in that
world it's a big risk both to thinness
between the self-employed and the
employees but also to the public
finances to have this large gap look for
some of people you're talking about just
now an IT worker sitting neck in a firm
an expensive item worker admittedly but
in a firm if that person is an employee
costing the firm 100,000 pounds they are
paying seven thousand pounds a year more
into the excha employed on a
self-employed basis you might think you
may well think that some gap is
justified but it definitely can't be
justified on that scale that is a real
issue Chris isn't it well I actually
think whoresons incorrect on this I
think it can be justified because that
self-employed worker is responsible for
in its entirety the employee benefits
that the employee he's working next it
gets from the company for example
training pension contributions sickness
pay even holiday pay if you're
self-employed you are on your own and
you know once the state pension may be
there for you at the end of the day
you're a contributory pension which
auto-enrolment captures for the
employees just doesn't exist but
ultimately the point is that
self-employed people make exactly the
same demands of the state as employed
people why should they pay less tax well
in fact I think that's incorrect only
are the evidence that we have shows it
self employed people take less sick days
that they rarely sign on for jobseekers
learns in between contracts the our
evidence is just the opposite in fact
the self-employed work harder take the
burden upon themselves and in fact in
general perform better than in some
cases they would have done had they been
employed torsten is there a case for
saying that national insurance
contributions should just be abolished
we should just merge them with income
tax would that be a more sensible
measure in this day and age I mean it's
a it's a it's a taxes outlived its
usefulness in many ways isn't it well
let me come back that but just on the
point your guess was just making I don't
me to be really careful here about look
we want lots of people to have the
choice to be self-employed we wanted to
choose to be their own boss for some of
them a small percentage but for some of
them that are setting up their own
company employing other people that's a
good thing we want to encourage that but
that is not the majority of people who
are self-employed only eleven percent of
the self-employed actually employ are
the people in particular which I think
we should be really careful about kind
of saying you know employees who
remember makeup eighty-five percent of
our workforce are in somehow not wealth
creators not working hard not taking any
risks I mean you go and say that to
somebody on low pay on a zero-hours
contract and I don't think they'll take
you suicide in which let's be careful we
want to support the self-employed I'm in
favor of that I mean flavor of greater
protection or their pension say but but
that does not mean that everybody else
is somehow I kind of schuyler this
living off the state